So Connor and I were in India.
We had flown there,
we were meeting with their judicial,
with the judges,
have their supreme court.
We arrived on that very day on that very
day.
Of course,
people that were horrified and there was
a tremendous outpouring of support and
people couldn't have been nicer.
And,
but it was a time for a thought.
And really it seemed to me the,
the,
and I mentioned it because,
uh,
what was in our minds after a week
there,
we spent a week there,
uh,
that the world is really divided into
the f.
What I think of is the forces of reason
and the forces of non reason and the
forces of reason.
Well,
law is part of that law as part of it.
Judges are part of it.
Lawyers are part of it.
And so is everybody else on,
you know,
other professions,
the forces of non reason,
that's the risk.
That's the danger.
So I rather see that as a,
as a something that's unifying people
across the world.
Because people across the world do
believe in democratic systems.
They do believe in protecting basic
human rights.
Uh,
they,
they do believe in drawing to create
economies that will be,
make their people prosperous and uh,
uh,
they believe to a considerable degree in
international settlement of disputes,
things like that too,
but therefore says that they have to
fight against,
which are obvious.
So that's in my mind,
maybe that's how I was brought up to,
you know,
it was after World War II and efforts at
cooperation.
I as you look out today,
but also I'd say my experience tells me
that in a way it's like this sort of
somebody weaving allume.
I mean,
I'm not a political figure.
I'm not in politics and I don't,
uh,
and,
and people who do are,
are in politics and in very high levels
in government may see these
international institutions and global
politics going on at a very high level.
But I say to the lawyers and judges were
technical people were professionals and
at our level,
whatever happens at the other,
there is a kind of knitting going off.
It's like workers at allume.
It's happening in Europe,
it's happening in Africa,
it's happening in Asia.
People are learning from each other,
particularly in law.
How does it happen?
It happens at conferences.
People talk to each other,
judges talk to each other,
lawyers talk to each other.
It happens as different groups.
Try to create laws.
For example in Europe they are trying to
uh,
create commercial laws and bankruptcy
laws and tax laws and laws that will
govern several what were independent,
they are independent nations but they're
trying to get together and this is
happening,
say the World Trade Organization
happening across the world.
It's popularly called globalization,
but what it involves or people in
business,
people in law learning what each other
are doing and they adjust their laws
accordingly.
It doesn't always have to be formal.
We used to have a group called the
uniform law commissioners and they go
from state to state and they'd say,
California does this.
And I go to Iowa and they say,
Iowa,
you know,
California does this,
maybe you should try it.
And that kind of thing goes on every
minute as we speak.
And then there,
there,
there are different organizations
developing,
well,
like the World Trade Organization or,
or there,
there are dozens of them there.
They're free trade areas are there,
there,
there are a health organizations,
there are communications organizations,
there's the internet,
there are all these things we know
about.
They are all forces working to bring us
together.
So what I see as happening,
and it's not a political matter,
what I see is happening is people who
are lawyers and judges in America today
have to be aware and they have to have a
system for being aware of what's going
on elsewhere because of the cases in
front of them will more and more depend
on what's happened.
Yeah.